there's no time
[Music]
13 o clock hey here we are again and
it's episode 157 yeah this is gonna be
an interesting one we why did you say it
like that you know I've been hearing
this one off and on my whole [ __ ]
life yeah me too yeah this one from
lucky in search of I know when I
rewatched in so Jeff today just like
yeah episode about it yeah yeah somebody
put it on YouTube yeah it's the
interesting case it is and this was
actually a recommendation by one of our
YouTube listeners this is the Lost
Dutchman's mine
yeah and other kind of mysterious [ __ ]
around the Superstition Mountains
because a lot of people go missing the
Superstition Mountains yeah it's like
small West [ __ ] you know
it is all West yeah but yeah so a lot of
people like go missing and turn up
murdered and they find like skulls with
like that and there's supposed to be a
curse - so like something you see Clint
Eastwood doing walking around getting
badly because anybody has anybody made
like a horror movie based on the Lost
Dutchman right I know I've seen like a
couple of documentaries about it but I
feel like that would make like I don't
know that might not be enough there well
I don't know you I don't know boom
tomahawk would probably pretty close
that's true we need to do a review of
that one these days cuz it's another
crustle movie because yeah that was
really good
it really is great cuz it didn't I buy
you that for Christmas or your birthday
or something like that yeah a Western
[ __ ] Stark Russell yeah at anything
he's in his element yeah yeah
they should make more horror westerns I
guess they make it sound like one of my
favorite ones is ravenous actually II I
guess isn't a Western Western it's
actually set during it every war
all right so like I said this was a
request and this was something that
again like you know I saw a lot of in
[ __ ] you know on documentaries and
stuff on TV back in the day all those
like creepy mysterious kind of things so
this is something I had kind of
forgotten about and then when I started
reading about I'm like oh yeah I
remember all in this kind of stuff but
before we get to that let's do a couple
of shout outs yeah we one of our patrons
Liam
increased his support this week so thank
you very much
what's nice I don't I don't usually
write the amounts done I usually just
write the tags to keep it down low yeah
and also if you didn't notice I
mentioned on our show last week but
faceless Ville and volume three is now
available for sale yeah it's it's in
print and eBook formats the audiobook
format all the files have been uploaded
and about a week ago and they're
undergoing like quality control so I
imagine it'll probably be like another
weekend that should be available as well
yeah so I might actually I made like a
little commercial for it and I might put
it in this episode but and I think the
commercial says that the audiobook
version is available but it probably
won't be for like another week or so
right but the print name over there are
available and I'll put like a link down
in the description yeah and her
collection of fiction is finished just
got to do the audio recording yeah I
read while the book looks really good oh
thanks yeah every did the I'm doing like
a second edition of I'm doing The
Associated villainies first if any
developer at that one it's like a you
know short stories and I basically
redesigned the cover I redid the layout
I added three or four more stories to
the end so I'm doing like a second
edition of it yeah and eventually it's
gonna have an audiobook version too I
just haven't got around to recording and
once that one's out any of our patrons
we can send him a free audiobook on me
on that one
yeah you know as a perk there yeah
unless you guys give a review on it it's
it's gonna be good though it's you know
if you like those old kind of like
Stephen King's short story compilations
it's like that but she's kind of more
like Clive Barker if you asked me yeah
yeah it's pretty gross it's cool one
story in particular because I had read
them in a while cuz some of them were
kind of old and like I was reading it
and I was like that's pretty disgusting
I can't believe it oh that's never been
available before on audiobook and it all
had to be kind of repackaged and
relaunched into easier to buy chunks you
know I mean so everything was big enough
we wanted everything they'd be at least
400 pages worth of material so these
will be a lot easier to buy than buying
a bunch of little ones it's gonna sell
well yeah I feel like I wanted to take
as you know and I think I mentioned this
on a show like a while back but I wanted
to take I have so many like unpublished
like short stories and like you know
just little bits of things that never
got published or got published in like
old anthologies that maybe people didn't
read and I was like you know I really
want to do like just a little series of
fiction books that are just like you
know novels or novellas or compilations
of short stories and I want them to all
be sort of like a series I want them all
to be 400 pages yeah so you feel like
you're getting your money's worth and I
want them all to eventually have
audiobook covers so that's so that's my
project that I'm working on now the
first one like I said is gonna be
associated villainies which even if you
have the original version this is gonna
have this an all-new cover like I said
there's some different stories in it and
it's gonna have an audiobook version and
then after that I'm gonna do hopeful
monsters and then I'm gonna say what I'm
gonna do from yeah and the audiobook
read it's gonna be real entertaining on
this one this isn't isn't gonna be kind
of drier clinical like some of the older
you know paranormal type books like in
you know that we're in the past where
you kind of had played a little straight
Jenny I'll be able to kind of act up and
it would be probably more about like
that listening to this show probably
yeah I mean because it's fiction so you
can do them like I'm not gonna do wacky
voices already no I'm not going that far
but you know
it's all about entertainment yeah so I
might like I so it might be like kind of
livelier and Jen like that but we'll see
how it goes so that's kind of that's
something I'm gonna be working on over
the next couple of months yeah
so are we ready to talk about the Lost
Dutchman mine yeah but you didn't have
anything else you need oh yeah oh he did
yeah
somebody commented saying that the show
is suffering because the out drink in
the alcohol oh so I blocked his ass now
this is really suffering for him I got a
bad temper you don't like a shows don't
watch it you know if you're up there
it's a very easy thing that some people
don't really see they don't stand doing
they don't understand it
I'll shut that [ __ ] before we were just
taking take a comment down but I [ __ ] I
can get vindictive I'll [ __ ] ban your
ass back the [ __ ] out of you I guess I
can do that well you know the mentally
ill people have to make comments every
day oh then I guess yeah it keeps him
out of trouble
[Laughter]
yeah so do the show all right so now are
you ready okay like I said this way my
whole oh my god I gotta mention
something else going into intense
intense study for the martial arts
paranormal show that we're doing that
will probably be the next probably the
next one he's very excited about yeah
I'm very excited like showing me all
these videos yeah videos and all kinds
of stuff than historical documentation
that I found online I guess yes you say
it's to historical there's not a whole
lot that I'm not sure is actually
legitimate and a lot of this martial
arts stuff but it is very entertaining
yes some of this very some of those
videos that you showed me especially
that one guy I was just yeah some some
Wow
yeah well I was sure I showed her the
the videos of a martial art master known
as Ishida can and he's to sell videos to
his students through comic books I guess
like that magazine
and man these we're gonna we're having
clips of somebody's trading but if I if
he doesn't sue me he's still alive right
I don't think so you it's fair it's fair
uh it's very usage okay even if we're
making fun we don't have to make fun of
those we just show ya you really no
further comment it's just like yeah he
was one of the greatest martial artists
and then I kind of wonder if like people
back then like some little kid like
ordered it for the back of a comic when
I was like even like it was so long ago
like would you feel ripped off or would
you be like yeah man epic the guy felt
ripped off they didn't know although my
buddy Jim he was all into that she he
probably loved that [ __ ] eat it up
that's what I mean if you're super into
that stuff you're a kid and it was like
the 80s or whatever it was and you
didn't know anything and your craze in
the 80s yeah yeah so you know they might
not have [ __ ] up it was during the
satanic panic too man but the ninjas
never got ninjas never got accused of
being Satanists I get this two things
they really know each other although
most arrogance
they're both most of the things they
accused of being I'm actually surprised
now that you mentioned I was yeah as
that [ __ ] didn't get dragged into oh man
they you look at it ninja that you could
say that guy was satanic yeah he's black
and he can do you like dragons and he's
trying to kill people and yeah I guess
worships the devil not Christian yeah
cuz not he's not from here as a heathen
alright yeah that'll be it that's a
little teaser of next week like I said
he's very I'm gonna talk about all the
great so he decided to do this yeah
talk about all that's because you've
been doing research on this for like
weeks in week so it's like they'll take
some of the burden off me I guess count
Dante then talk about [ __ ] talk about
Frank Dux they're Dukes Frank Dux talk
about all kinds of people all right but
on this show we're gonna talk about the
Superstition Mountains and in particular
the legend of the Lost Dutchman mine and
like I said this area suppose I'll so
supposed to be cursed like an Apache
curse or something like that this is
probably one of the best known I
wouldn't even say one of the best this
is the best known like treasure hunt
story like treasure curse story in
American history I think there's really
not one better no than this is there
maybe not in America where was that one
what was that pirate treasure and I
think it was on Captain Kidd one weekend
an island and they thought that there
was this dam shaft Oh Oak Island Oak
Island yeah I would say his prior up
there was kind of like Oh God yeah
that's got a whole like series about
that same spot forever there's nothing
there no I think they're not found it by
now
but you know makes a good series I guess
but I think the well the difference
between Oak Island in this case was that
this case has won some murders and to it
has like that kind of like that Apache
curse aspect okay also and also like
people still go missing looking for this
[ __ ] even though technically you're not
supposed to go looking for treasure and
the Superstition Mountains anymore
because it's like a protected area now
okay um but people still do it anyway
and they're still dragging people's
carcasses out of there every now and
then because they think they're - I'm
gonna go find a treasure map and I'm
gonna go like in here with no [ __ ]
water not enough food it's like yeah I
mean there's just no hiking boots
sustain life for long no it definitely
won't
yeah you just really can't mean hardly
anything grows there it's just like all
scrub and it's just you know it's like
hundreds and hundreds of degree like
100-something degrees in the day and
it's like freezing cold at night and I
think a lot of people go
they're a little unprepared yeah so you
know and they've been doing that for
years and years and like I said a lot of
them died and some of them disappear
also so you know and that kind of like I
think that kind of like um plays into
the whole mystique around the place
because all these people go missing and
it's like oh it's cuz the curse I think
this is kind of the area where a couple
of convicts they thought were out hiding
out there went missing sometime in the
80s in the early 80s some guys were I
think they did a bank robbery and during
the during the they had like a little
shootout with the cops so they got into
a vehicle and were shooting out the back
of it and they got away yeah yeah they
had assault rifles and stuff and
evidently they were never seen or heard
from again
hmm and some people there were some
reports of somewhere in the desert and I
think it was around this area they
thought they saw two of them they had
rifles and everything but they just look
like Haggard old Bob's with rifles and
they were trying to just evidently live
off the land out there that good like
something out of Hills Have Eyes I never
found those guys again I forgot the name
and I've got all the details just
remember that now yes
somebody somebody might know and like I
said a lot of people have disappeared I
mean they found a lot of bodies like
they found a lot of skeletons and stuff
out there but like some people just said
hey I'm going to find the Lost Dutchman
mine and they never saw their asses
again yeah so I think the last report so
those guys who want to run out in the
desert that was probably 90 state Burton
they probably dead by now well yeah yeah
like unless they got the found the [ __ ]
they were never found again yeah they're
you know they're wanted men and there
are places where you could disappear in
the United States never be seen again
well yeah there's lots of places like
the desert wouldn't be a good place well
maybe it'd be better to up in there in
Washington State some of those National
Forest forest instead I mean they're
just really never a good place to do
anything because you know very hard to
live off the land when there's hardly
animals you can live my National Forest
though oh yeah easily
yeah not easier I mean yeah if you know
what you're doing you could just fish
all year round if you had to yeah and
you know that's that seems like one of
the easiest things to do
all right so as I said you know other
than Oak Island this is probably the
best-known kind of treasure tale from
the Old West
even though tales of it go way back to
you know the Spanish conquistador isn't
even like before that so the Lost
Dutchman mine as it came to be called
later on is actually a little bit east
of Phoenix Arizona in the very coolly
named superstition mountains
now there's one mountain that's just
called superstition Mountain but then
the whole range is called superstition
mountains - yeah and then there's one
kind of like peak and that's called
weavers needle and that usually comes up
a lot when they're talking about the
Luke you know the purported location of
the mind because some people said oh
it's in the shadow weavers needle and
stuff like that even though they've
never and some people have like tried to
plow all the way through a forest needle
like blast their way through it looking
for this [ __ ]
and they've never found anything so all
right now before you know anybody found
gold or before any of the prospecting or
anything like that when the Spanish got
to Arizona in around 1540 the area
around the mountains was inhabited by
the Apache Indians or Native Americans
yeah they were well you know they think
they might have killed a lot of the
people that went in there looking for
the gold I don't remember exactly how
old the Apache Tribe were but I do
remember that the Apache weren't around
for very long they were actually made up
out of three other tribes that had kind
of got whittled down and next to nothing
and then a bunch of bandits mixed in
with them and they weren't around but I
think about 30 or 40 years but these
guys were [ __ ] awesome they were
really good ambush fighters out in the
desert their trademark was [ __ ]
slavery they enslaved other in India
especially women they were doing like
white slavery and stuff you know with
Indian women you know these are bad
dudes nobody liked him evidently no and
the US Army with the aid of some other
Indian tribes supposedly hunted them
down and kind of pacified him of it
eventually that was the story I
remembered they're still around and I
think I think they actually might even
have a reservation but they're not
talking
the same they're not really the same
guys anymore you know they're not
criminals or anything of course well yes
I think many generations nay I saw him
on Ultimate Warrior they were they were
doing like it cuz they handsome like a
patchy fighting techniques and sure
whatever happened in that show
it's kind of fun don't know how Pennock
it was it's not but it was out there
doing their [ __ ] [ __ ] and clicking
with their knives and [ __ ] you know it
was uh it was pretty cool you know
of course you know we're talking about
you know 1800s and you know these guys
weren't [ __ ] Stone Age you know they
were also real they traded with the
Mexico a lot so they had guns and knives
and steel and they were modern people
you know in those days they weren't far
from yeah they shot on these old
westerns you know kind of like how the
Indians and guys in the Wild West were
like in a parallel universes like the
evenings are still in Stone Age
know they're like runner oh the law in
class how was Indians had money money
they they traded they made money you had
rich Indians he had unions of war
clothes and had shipped on the horses
and some of the best [ __ ] guns that
you could buy you know repeating rifles
and stuff you know they were fully aware
what the [ __ ] was going on they were
they were modern players in the game you
know but yeah you look patchy and of
course you know being US Army all of our
badass [ __ ] was named after some kind of
Indian tribe their ferocity but patchy
helicopter yeah
and this Chinook you know and all that
kind of stuff everything is bad at US
Army ever the motifs were always a idiot
yeah yeah it's getting an honor of these
[ __ ] a fight yeah mom well they
were survivors you know they could SWAT
in the field you know in a day with a
white man who couldn't feed himself in
the field you know he's starving you
know needed to help the Indians you know
to teach him how to survive off the land
you know yeah that's what I was all
meant it was all [ __ ] man love and
[ __ ] it sound like these dudes are
badasses
it's so hilarious because it's like I
remember when I was a little kid I don't
think they teach it like this anymore
but when I was a little kid you know the
myth around Thanksgiving and stuff like
in the United States was like oh you
know the pilgrims they shared their food
with day
like no kind of the other way how to
survive yeah because the people are like
oh my god there's yes what do you mean
we can't do it when they had it when
they have it when they had their first
big successful harvest they shared it
with the people that taught them how to
grow it yeah and that all those early
colonies if you look back into the
records there were all people that were
mixed they were Indians living with them
that had converted to Christianity they
were having children together same with
Salem the whole Salem town you know
where the Salem witch trials went you
can look in the records and it was
mostly an Indian town really and most of
those they had in American names but
there just weren't enough people there
weren't enough women to marry you
married Indian women yeah it's like as
always you know the history is a lot
more complex and interesting it was not
brown and white no red and white no
those towns were all mixed yeah
and they were black people in those
towns well like not surprisingly because
everyone just kind of like right you
were in a little bit of a hostile
environment particularly for the
European settlers so you know you took
the help you could get you'd be stupid
not to yeah and you know all through the
SEVIS 1617 and part of the eight all
through the 16 and 1700s well actually
you can go to the late 1500 the white
man had to live as an Indian when he got
here basically yeah you had to adapt
their ways that goes back to you know
yeah like I said they've been here for
thousands of years your ass just got
here right so you better listen to the
people that wrote here we know there was
no cultural power really you know until
1707 Teno OS and then Industrial
Revolution changed the game and you know
you're gonna hear all this [ __ ] about
Indian genocides there's a lot of
battles you know I mean main thing was
disease and a disease is bought by the
Spaniards in the end hundreds so it was
already kind of opposed to pock elliptic
yeah I mean the population had been
significantly too many from diseases
before the first English colonies ever
got here and then they got there you
don't know one of the first guys they
meet with Squanto and he
got back from England so you had Indians
in England yeah and they knew all you
know they speak English and [ __ ] so it
was a more of a globalized world than
people think it was but disease got most
of them and then there's a bunch of
trading alliances and and and Wars and
inbreeding or it sees me a lot of out
breeding you know Indian men were real
popular with white women there's all
kinds of stories of women running away
you know the army looking for them
saving the woman and then then they wake
up the next morning the woman's gone
because you know like I know I wanted to
go yeah ever so big'uns leave me alone
live in the indian lifestyle was a lot
better than living the white man's life
I can have no status totally see there's
a lot more free yeah there's a lot more
practical Europeans kind of had some bad
habits at that time you know and the
Indians didn't have those they had bad
habits too but not quite those same bad
habits yeah because you know people are
just what they are you know people
aren't rose
anyway what ended up getting in Indians
really were cars cars in a railroad he
just once that happened then all of a
sudden people started putting fences up
and you just couldn't go out and hunt
the Buffalo like the Lakota did at that
point you're walking through other
people's land yeah it just didn't there
so everybody just got jobs yeah you know
and everybody married other people and
they just we friend of ours is an Indian
princess Tori yeah and she's got blonde
hair blonde hair rainbow colored hair
and blue eyes
she's a Mac ha yeah she's a mac off her
dad is um isn't her dad likes I've been
watching these native Indian oceans or
something like that yeah
she's one of the almost kind of like an
Eskimo type Indian they were they hunted
whale and stuff up in Washington State
yeah whereas I know they still have
rights to do that yeah they're the only
Americans that got hot oil
yeah if you're told this anyway yeah so
um yeah so when the Spaniards first got
to Arizona in 15-round 1540 all the area
around the Superstition Mountains that
was you know occupied occupied by the
Apache
now the Superstition Mountains were
considered kind of
sacred area some sources I read said
that because they thought it was like
the source of that the you know where
their Thunder God lived some of them
said it was like kind of a hole to hell
or whatever that type of thing we like
the underworld or whatever but in any
case the Spaniards found out that the
Apache said that there was gold in there
but see the Apache the gold that was
ostensibly in the Superstition Mountains
was put there for them like for their
use so other people were not supposed to
go in there and get it and really they
had a belief I was like watching that on
that in search of show and they had a
guy and I think the show was came out
and maybe the early 80s late seventies
early eighties and they had one guy on
there who was like a spokesman for him
like that what was left at the Apache
Tribe there and he was talking about you
know white man is not supposed to go
into the Superstition Mountains you're
supposed to do all this like rigmarole
to go in there he's like you know this
entrance is guarded by a male snake and
this other entrance is guarded by a
female snake and then there's like an
abalone shell and you have to put like a
particular stone in there so the snakes
don't get you and all this other kind of
stuff so they had like all of these like
myths surrounding these mountains that
you know that it was kind of just their
thing and you weren't supposed to go in
there that's why you know the fact that
they had these stories about it that's
why later on when like they started
finding all these skeletons and like
people sort of disappear in there and
[ __ ] they suspected that some of the
people had been killed by Apache because
Apaches didn't want them in there
understandably because that was like
their turf you know so alright so again
but when the Spaniards get there it
seems like every time they heard
somewhere had gold in it they were all
over that [ __ ] so this first contingent
comes led by Francisco Vasquez de
Coronado and they thought since the
Apache
said something about there being gold in
the Superstition Mountains they said oh
that must be one of the sites of one of
this seven golden golden Cities of
Cibola one of they're you know it's kind
of like El Dorado we're kind of because
you know how like this band
they had all these myths about like
cities made out of gold and [ __ ] like
that they had a bunch of different names
for it so they thought that maybe that's
what this so that's what that was
so they said we need to go in there and
like find that [ __ ] now the Apache told
them they're like nah no bro we're not
gonna help you that's like that's where
the Thunder God lives he's gonna [ __ ]
you up if you go in there Catrin just
can't break it it's like you know if you
go in there like there will be horrible
suffering they'll be like all these
horrible deaths like they called the
mountains that Devil's playground so of
course the Spaniards did not listen to
this there let's just like the hell with
your legends we just want some gold so
we're gonna go in there anyway so they
start like poking around in there and
then dude started disappearing just like
the Apache said what happened well they
were probably up in there
yes the Apaches were master of the
ambush that's what I mean so I feel like
like I said I think a lot of the legends
around the curse like surrounding this
mountain stuff like that might have just
been like Apache banila are from flower
right we're just gonna [ __ ] up people to
come in here because they're not
listening to us about staying out of
here so we're just gonna go in there and
kill him well if I remember correctly
the the Apaches one of their men one of
their main things was was ambushing
supply lines and roads that's yeah I
made a living they were kind of like
they were kind of like the Hells Angels
of Indians or the Pirates of Indians you
know I mean and so they they stole it
stole people that came into their
territory their territory was like a
trap that's how they got so famous for
being fierce yeah they killed a lot of
people yeah they kill a lot of people in
need and slaved a lot of people and
slaved a lot of Indians and killed a lot
of other Indians they were at war with a
bunch of other Indians around him you
know nobody liked him yeah we're kind of
like the Klingons yeah they were
respected though you know the man can
fight they were willing to fight they
were you know nomadic kind of well
the area you know yeah yeah they're
badasses but yeah so I feel like so like
I said a lot of the Spaniards go in
there they wouldn't come out and they
would find them later like with their
heads cut off and [ __ ] like that
so of course the Spaniards like thinking
oh [ __ ] the curse is true so finally
after that happened enough times they're
like alright just never mind and then
they just left
however they were the ones apparently
the Spaniards were the ones that named
it superstition mountain for that very
reason because of all the stories
surrounding it now there's nothing
really like to report for the next like
hundred and fifty years or so but then
this there's this Jesuit priest
his name is Eusebio Francisco Kino and
he was coming to do like they did like
build a mission and like bring Jesus to
the savages and all that whatnot yeah
but he also heard tales about gold in
the Superstition Mountains and thought
that maybe he should like look into that
so um in about 1710 right around there
he started looking around now he did
find some gold
although nobody knows if he found it in
the Superstition Mountains are just like
around there somewhere you know what I
mean because there's there's a thing
about the Lost Dutchman mine where the
guy that kind of gave it its name who
was actually a German not a Dutch guy
I'll get into that later but um but that
he did actually like find gold but some
people are thinking that maybe he told
people it was in the Superstition
Mountains just to like throw them off
but it was actually like somewhere else
nearby like because he didn't want
anybody like so they were known on his
dick there were no witnesses to him
actually digging that gold out of the
ground well none that lived or nothing
read anything and we're not talking
about coins these are ingots right here
not Angus uh these are just naturally
okay oh yeah it's like it's like you
know places a quartz you have no veins
like then like nugget sister yeah all
right okay yeah get those yeah you can
get those you don't have to dig those up
you know makes me wonder if that was
something he just got his
and share with other people he said he
got it from there that's I mean he did
apparently find a lot but I don't really
know they claimed that he found a lot of
it he kept showing up with it
yeah well that guy did but you know like
I said they're not entirely sure where
he got it because some some people that
are like experts in this kind of thing
and you know I don't know cuz I'm not an
expert but they say that the
Superstition Mountains are not generally
the kind of Rock is I think it's igneous
rock and there's like that's not usually
the kind of rock where gold veins are
found there has been gold found in
places around there and there are other
there are gold mines like functioning
gold mines around there or there were
back then so it's not like there's no
gold in the air at all they're just
talking about the Superstition Mountains
in particular is probably not a good
place to look if you're looking for like
you know gold or like a vein of gold ore
because it's not usually the kind of
rocks that then that that would appear
in okay he shows up with gold he says he
got it out of there yeah immediately
yeah now this like I said this first guy
he starts showing up you know they they
don't know if this is where this this
gold came from but he did start showing
up with you know of significant amount
of gold enough that people noticed
pretty much so that kind of like added
more fuel to the fire of like the
legends and [ __ ] like that but again the
more people you know the more he came
back and said you know yeah that he had
found gold there like people started
noticing that he found gold there the
Apache started getting more and more
pissed off about it so they just decided
okay [ __ ] it we're just killing
everybody that comes in here or
attacking them you know what I mean it's
just trying to scare everybody away so
many so several years later in 17 what
we can hold on that no what year was
what years is that was that priests came
and what about 1710 okay so this is a
long time ago uh-huh okay so this is
before the this is before the war
between the United States and the Apache
yeah this is a long time so they're not
pacified yet right and what pacified all
right I didn't know that the Apache
existed that far
mm-hmm I thought that they were an 1800s
Indian tribe than 1800s only but maybe
yeah maybe so yeah yeah I mean because a
lot of them didn't last they weren't lot
of tribes only lasted a few generations
three four generations they break apart
you know become other tribes or you know
gets whatever they get small and another
tribe kind of swallow them up you know
Miriam yeah that's a all right well I
guess so I have I haven't I haven't read
a really good modern book about the
Indians in a long time
yeah there's old tribes I need to get
back into that see if they found out
more information about them it is really
interesting all this yeah sure he felt
like there really early like
pre-european settlement yeah
history well I know that the Lakota were
the biggest ones in the it was a huge
tribe made up of a bunch of different
little sub tribes
yeah and a lot of people you know like
the if I remember correctly the Sioux
was a French term for one of the Lakota
tribes yeah I think the crow might have
been the part of the Lakota tribes act
it would they were loosely organized
bands but they did know what groups they
belonged to yeah I need to find that I
mean I need to read more about that it's
been a long time I think that was
similar to what happened like here in
Florida like everybody's you know like
we had the Seminole and stuff but I
think the Seminole were kind of like
they were like why evil well and they
were from other tribes - was it like
they weren't like oh this tribe and was
whatever they were just kind of like I
read I read what Jackson Jackson's
problem with him first of all they were
mercenaries working for the Spanish some
of them were Native Americans but a lot
of them were Irish and they had a lot of
black people that were also Seminole and
they were all kind of mixing together
and some of the some of them were
putting on what you call white men's
clothing jumping the border and going
back into the United States conducting
business and without paying any taxes
and then going back that was part of the
thing that was pissing pissing Jackson
off is that it was he saw his way of
dodging taxes you see if you go in there
and look at a lot of these people he
goes they're not Indians they're white
people they need to be paying taxes so
you gave them all ultimatum
become citizens they go out to Indian
Territory and the Seminole became
Americans yeah they didn't they didn't
go after the Indians own so you know
that's a sad way because you could play
Indian young yeah that's a good
lifestyle yeah and then then you could
go you can you could go to town too and
that was a good lifestyle so it was a
way of I guess getting all the best yeah
the best of both worlds you're claiming
to be in an Indian tribe and one of the
Five Civilized tribes and having all the
benefits of that but you're also wide
enough in western enough today I'm going
to town conduct business during the
saloon and you know do it every little
thing they'll say anything about it and
and you know you don't have to pay any
taxes and then later that caused a big
problem so Jackson the whole thing with
Jackson was about he said it was it was
dodging taxes which it may have been
maybe it was maybe it was relevant for a
few generations but it had gotten to the
point to where it didn't make any sense
anymore as well that's what that's
that's what they said yeah you know
maybe it made sense a hundred years
before that there eighty years before
that but everyone had become integrated
and it didn't make any sense anymore
yeah always like slower to catch up as
always what situation was you know what
are you gonna do but they're still here
kinda gotta the names of the Seminole
though well they actually had been
flooded by everybody else from New York
coming here although Florida is full of
Indian place names yeah our malls named
a from this women we learn we live in a
Seminole County this is where the
Seminole were what's this yeah yeah we
live in Silla and they were actually
fighting on the side of the Spanish for
a long time yeah but then like the war
gets them lasted like one day I don't
even think anybody was killed and then
they decided now we'll flip sides then
they became a big they start they
supported the United States out of that
well span this pain couldn't offer him
anything at that time the money the
money in Spain had dried
yeah yeah paint could paint couldn't
hold on Florida anymore yeah we were
this is Spanish territory really yeah or
it was at one time a lot of it still
looks like Spain people yeah give me a
new buildings they build here like all
these little houses in about little
Spanish houses well like I said any
castles if you go to st. Augustine which
is not only a few miles from here and it
is the oldest permanent settlement in
the United States yeah that is a Spanish
fort in a Spanish village yeah so the
fort there is called Castillo de San
Marcos yeah it's pretty cool actually I
imagine all kinds of Europeans that want
to come they shoot the cannons and
everything imagine all kinds of
Europeans oh come on would like to come
down here and trip out on all this
Indian stuff and old-fashioned American
[ __ ] Old West stuff oh yeah we don't
have like yeah we don't have home like
Oh granted we don't have all the
colonial [ __ ] like they have a little
bit like up in New England and stuff
then we do have like a lot of old
Spanish yeah got Spanish though yeah all
right so like I said um so the Jesuit
priest came and like you know he
apparently found some gold either in the
superstitions or somewhere around there
so you know rumors started to get more
rumor started to get around people like
oh there's gold in there and then the
Apache were like man [ __ ] now we're just
gonna have to kill everybody that comes
in there now in 1748 the superstitions
as they're called and there was also
about almost 4,000 square miles of land
surrounding that in Arizona although it
was in Arizona then obviously yeah it
was just a it was Mexico probably yeah
um we're actually given to a Mexican
cattle baron by the name of Don Miguel
Peralta now this was supposedly a land
grant now I have seen some sources the
the main source that I'm using for lists
this like the chronology and the notes
and everything are from like a site
about like American legends and like
American history and stuff I have seen
some sources that say that there is some
question about not that the I mean the
Peralta's did exist but you know whether
they actually did own this land at any
point
whether the land grant was a forgery
whether there's like all kind of
different things going on but the story
goes that the Peralta family got the got
the Superstition Mountains along with a
bunch of other land in a land grant in
1748 now the land not necessarily the
superstitions but the land around that
that they had actually did have a gold
mine and a silver mine so they did find
gold and silver on this particular land
I think that was actually more than one
silver mine on there so this is kind of
like the first inkling that there's like
an actual gold mine and a silver mine
and nests in this location so evidently
the Peralta family lived there you know
for the next hundred years something
like that like the you know descendants
of the family like lived there and they
had the mines there and worked on them
and brought out all kind of gold and
silver now they tried to like not piss
off the Apache um you know to varying
degrees of success so they tried to like
not take out too much or like tried to
keep it on the DL you know what I mean
so like the about you wouldn't get
pissed off at them and it seemed to have
worked for a while but then in 1846
there were four I don't know I guess
there were sons grandsons however long
the the period was of the Peralta family
whose name was Enrico Pedro Ramon and
Manuel they decided well we're gonna go
into Arizona and go into the
superstitions and look for some more
gold there now they apparently went
there I don't know if they went to the
superstitions or not but they went to
somewhere around there and they came
back with a whole [ __ ] ton of gold so
you know then they were like okay well
we need to like we came back okay we got
all this gold we're gonna go again next
year and get some more gold so they
decided to go back again however at this
point the Mexican War was you know kind
of raging full-on Miskin American War
yeah well yeah so um Pedro decided he
was the only one that said he was going
to go back
the other three were just like now it's
too dangerous so Paige I said okay well
I'm gonna go back there to Arizona I'm
gonna get as much gold as I can possibly
get before you know the outcome of the
war and like this because this land
might go back to Mexico and then or
might go to the United States and then
we won't have rights over it anymore or
something like that so they wanted to go
extract as much as they could extract
now he decides to go back and the Apache
are pissed off about it so apparently
there was like kind of a conflict and
then when the Peralta's left when Pedro
left and everything like that they said
okay well we're gonna take all the gold
we can take and that we are going to
hide the entrance of the mine and just
cover it up and we're just not going to
tell anybody where it is and we're just
gonna take all the gold we took and get
the [ __ ] out of here like before we get
our asses killed and that's legend goes
that that's what they did so that's why
people are saying this like oh nobody
knows where the mine is and stuff
because they said oh well the Peralta's
had the mind because they found like all
this gold of evidently but they sealed
it up and wouldn't tell anybody where it
was just you know because they had all
the gold they needed and it's like they
didn't want anybody else to find it
they're like well maybe we'll be able to
go back later and get it or some [ __ ]
like that
you know uh Shire he's a subscriber he's
from he's from Mexico
he's buddy of mine he's over in TJ he's
in Tijuana
we were online discussing the
mexican-american war I was always under
the impression that we just kind of took
the Southwest that's kind of how its
portrayed but not really it was
technically we bought it we were in a
kind of conflict over Texas Santa Ana
was in charge of Mexico at that time and
he was kind of a dictator all right and
there was kind of a rebellion against
Santa Ana fomenting against him and he
really couldn't fight two wars at once
and Texas was kind of disputed a bunch
of Americans were moving in there like
illegal aliens in a way they weren't
they didn't want to obey a mix
in law and it was pretty complicated how
it went but Mexico broke off relations
with us over that and a war broke out
and I don't think very many mixes were
killed in that first battle I think it
was like 200 men and money I don't know
I don't remember exactly what the
numbers were
but anyway Santana basically gave up he
sued for peace he says okay if you want
it you can have it you just gotta pay me
15 million for so we gave him the
fifteen million dollars so really was
purchased yeah a lot I see a lot of it
had to do with that Louisiana Purchase
yeah okay well that Louisiana Purchase
was kind of disputed by Spain in Mexico
certain zones and areas of it
there definitely we didn't have
California and Nevada and New Mexico and
we didn't really have Texas but that all
got settled during that war with Santa
Ana Santa Ana said we could have it all
for 34 I think was 13 million so we just
said yeah yeah okay I'll take it so we
just bought it I thought we just took it
but no we bought it and then there was
that Treaty of Guadalupe you know which
was designated the modern border between
the United States and Mexico that was
that was part of what we bought yeah
that that's where it begins and that's
where it ends because Mexico really had
inherited that claim to that land
through Spain that's what Spain claimed
yeah but the Mexican Revolution through
Spain out so technically that wasn't
Mexico's climate with Spain's claim and
all these claims were European claims
anyway and they weren't enough troops to
enforce anything and everybody's mapped
look differently the only way you were
gonna decide who owned that land was a
fight for it or to buy it and make an
agreement yeah so that's just what it
looks like what else could he do back
then I'm just everything was like a
giant cluster everybody claimed
everything right so it's like well we
said the French have this man yeah
Spanish has this man English we own all
this [ __ ] they're like no we own it
every European superpower and
probably China had a claim on it to
going back to when they first came here
[ __ ] 2000 years but because they sent
a damn Navy over here to the fight in
the 1500s and there was evidently a name
he ran out of California
I think there's evidence that there's
China ancient Chinese anchors out there
off the coast of California yeah I'm not
sure I read a book about that a long
time ago I think it was called 1491 or
something like that or maybe I'm
thinking of a different thing but I
think I read a book about it but I don't
know a chance yeah I don't know if
that's been definitively proved but you
know anything could happen like I said
[ __ ] I was reading something the other
day that said you know there's a slim
possibility that the ancient [ __ ]
Phoenicians yeah
discovered America well this whole this
whole car thing you know he's described
as a white man with blue eyes and a
beard that taught them everything that
they knew and they're talking about
2,000 years ago yeah so how the hell did
he get here right that was in Mexico
get out well maybe somebody went through
the Straits of Gibraltar in a storm got
him and he washed up there you know
might have been some kind of an ancient
Greek trading vessel that's what I mean
because it had somebody on there you
know they knew how to work with stone
because I mean they know for sure that
the Phoenicians were like the powerhouse
like sailors okay ancient times and they
know that they went past the Straits of
Gibraltar they know they went like
really far they might have
circumnavigated Africa you know they
think they got to the Indian Ocean so
it's like they got pretty far so it's
not that crazy to think that maybe I
mean maybe they didn't do it on purpose
but it's not that crazy to think that
they maybe kind of stumbled across
there's a bunch of weird [ __ ] how the
hell did black people get on Easter
Island off the coast of Chile they were
there a long long time ago you know did
they come out of Australia that's what I
mean it's like that's a long way away it
is but you know I guess anything can
happen given enough time yeah that's I
think people forget it's like that one
thousands of years and it's like plus
they had boats and [ __ ] and it's like
they're made
you don't they had to happen once or
twice and a civilization might come and
go we have no record of it might have
been too far back I know isn't that
freaky to think yeah right that's one
reason I think so I wish somebody would
like invent a time machine just just so
you could like go back and see what the
[ __ ] happened cuz I'm just fascinated by
that kind of mysteries and like the
longer ago it is it's like the less
likely here how am I gonna know and that
like that really annoys me cuz I really
you know what I mean well there wasn't
we know that there wasn't anybody in the
Americas until after that damn
short-faced bear went extinct after the
Ice Age yeah you just humans couldn't
live alongside the short-faced bear his
that short-faced bear was a dick yeah so
and you know when you talk about Indians
you're not talking about one people
there's a lot of different kinds Adam
and they were coming from probably all
the other continents so you know because
[ __ ] up in the Northeast the first uh
you know first colonies showed up
reported back that oh the Indians look
like us you know and if you go down to
the if you go down into the into the
into the southwest the Indians look kind
of Mexican because of course you know
that's where it's in that area yeah so
you know you're not talking about one
race of people so I think the American
continent had been invaded over and over
and over again over the past [ __ ]
fifty thousand miss its kind of big yeah
so I think over the past twenty five
probably twenty five thousand years I
think so like I said all it would take
was like a couple of boats to get blown
out of course they're like oh where the
[ __ ] are wait yeah oh well I guess we're
stuck here now and I guess you could
probably walk into northern northeastern
candor a time you good child actually
for quite a long time you could so that
might explain why the people in New
England the Indians in the New England
area back in the 1400s were reported as
well it looked kind of like white people
it looked just like us yeah that's not
my only explanation they might have been
partly European like I said I think
there was a lot more traveling going on
back then than people like realize but
as I said I'm getting for a long time
people didn't think what you know I
remember back when I was a kid and
people would say simply go Vikings like
discovered America and
like it sounds like [ __ ] but no no
they were there I mean they didn't like
colonize to any great extent they only
had like a few settlements and stuff but
they know for sure that they were there
now we're here before Columbus they
would yeah way before like I've been you
know yeah that [ __ ] like that so who
knows what they'll discover in the
future I don't think those colonies tuck
though no they did they actually weren't
there for very long well they were
they're back yeah they were there for a
time and then they went back because
it's just I guess it wasn't really worth
it to them it was only like a few major
settlements okay so let's see was so one
of the Peralta's I think like Pedro like
I said he's like okay we're gonna get
all the gold we can get the and seal up
the miner or get the [ __ ] out of here
now this was over the winter of 1847
1848 so they load up all the burros with
gold like him and all his crew and
everything like that and they're getting
the [ __ ] out of there and then they get
attacked by the Apaches now the pack
mules apparently like kind of ran off
and like all the gold went all over the
place
so for a while the story goes that there
was just gold scattered everywhere until
like all the prospectors came and like
picked it off and [ __ ] and also there's
a story that in the 1850s two
prospectors had gone in they're looking
for you know looking for a vein of gold
and they found three dead burrows with
pack saddles that had 37 thousand
dollars worth of gold in it so this was
supposedly when they were leaving and
they all got killed by Apaches
so let's some stop for a moment because
we're almost in an hour so let's stop
for a moment to take a break because it
looks like you probably need to refresh
your drink I'm alright with mine right
now but your ice is falling out Pookie's
being good she's sleeping behind the
laptop she she's only moved the camera
this one time so we're hoping that she's
sleepy enough to know let's start
writing here and [ __ ] with all the
equipment but so we're gonna take a
break right now we'll be back in just a
few minutes
oh it's your chicken stick get it you're
just gonna push it right off of there
aren't you well now look what happened
you want me to get it for you want me to
get it don't you go over there and chew
on that [ __ ]
here here nope yeah it's good right it's
good yummy know you love true crime
I love true crime and I've spent the
last three years compiling a series of
the most intriguing unsolved murders of
the 20th century it's called the
faceless villain and volume three is
available now featuring such fascinating
cases as the Caddy murders the carry
babies case the Frog Boys the al-qasr
murders and the inokashira park
dismemberment incident the faithless
villain volume three is an involving
exploration of unsolved slang spanning
the years from 1980 to 1999 pick up your
copy and print or eBook formats on
Amazon or download the audiobook version
from audible.com and get ready for a
chilling journey through modern crime
history
all right so we're back from the break
now before we went I was talking about
poor old Pedro Peralta and his coming
out of this that coming out of the
[ __ ] canyons of the Superstition
Mountains and getting ambushed by Apache
and they all got killed and all their
gold got scattered and everything like
that so now after that happened the
Perrault the rest of the Peralta family
who still owned mines in the area were
understandably um a little gun-shy going
back into the area to mine any more gold
so it was about 16 years before anyone
else like decided to venture back out
there but finally Enrico Peralta took
400 guys out into the superstitions to
look for gold look for the mine look for
whatever however just as in the case of
poor Pedro he gets to the Northwest
slope of the mountain him and his 400
dudes and they are ambushed by Apaches
who kill all but one of the party that
way he could take a message back that's
probably why they left him alive just
like I 10 just like the Klingons yeah go
back and warn the others yeah and
apparently that area of the mountains is
still to this day known as massacre
ground see there's the title of your
horror movie right there get on that
writers will say you know this is really
good I think I make a hell of an action
scene with all those [ __ ] Apaches
that's what I mean and they just like
[ __ ] everyone up man you got all your
heads off and all this yeah alright so
the next kind of significant dude in
this story and I I say that kind of like
because according to the Wikipedia page
and like I said I read the Wikipedia
page and it's you know it's not super
well-written it's kind of all over the
place but like this one that was on
legends of America or whatever the site
is called was like way better it was
like a four page like breakdown now no
one is exactly sure if this dr. Abraham
thorn person who was like the next you
know big deal like in this myth or in
the legend around this mine was a real
dude now a lot of these people were real
dudes because they
like you know records of them and [ __ ]
like the Peralta family and the later
like Jacob waltz and later the later guy
that it was named after but this guy
they're not really sure they don't have
like a record of a doctor Abraham thorn
that you know in this area at the time
but that doesn't mean he wasn't a real
guy but it's just I don't know if
there's if he's a real guy or not but so
the next part of the legend says that
dr. Abraham thorn in 1865 was working as
an army doctor in Arizona at Fort
McDowell now by this point you know
relations between the Apache and the US
Army were not good so you know they were
kind of fighting in the Apache were also
fighting against all the settlers coming
into Arizona now there was a reservation
established and dr. Abraham thorn was
apparently working on this reservation
and he treated some Apache for some like
did for some disease that they had and
the story goes that the Apache showed
their appreciation to dr. thorn by
telling him that they would show him
where there was some gold in the
superstitions but the caveat being that
he couldn't know exactly where they were
so they took his ass there blindfolded
so the story goes yeah that sounds like
a story yes so like I said like a lot of
the players in this are like real people
because they have records of them this
guy not so much so I'm not really sure
entirely where this story came from but
this is like a big part of the legend so
apparently the the Apache said okay just
put the blindfold on and we'll take you
out to the superstitions it was a 20
mile journey now apparently he says that
he gets there they take the blindfold
off and he was near the mine entrance
and there was like a pile of gold or
like stacked near the base of the canyon
like the wall of the canyon so he said
that there was like a weird like a rock
pinnacle that was off to the south which
some people always assume is weavers
needle that's where all this stuff comes
about you know the Lost Dutchman's
behind being in
shadow flavors needle because they
assumed that's what he was talking about
so the Indians apparently said you can
take as much of that gold ore as you can
carry
and then we're gonna put the blindfold
on you and you know and get out of here
and don't come back
so apparently dr. Thorne ended up
selling this gold ore that he picked up
for about six thousand dollars which
back in the day that was a lot of money
so apparently though what happened was
that he kind of went back on his promise
so the story goes and he told some of
his friends and they actually went and
found the mine and they were like woohoo
and they like put all the gold and [ __ ]
in their saddlebags and then they're
like we were we're rich and everything
in while they're going out of the
superstitions you pass she's like okay
guys that story goes it sounds like a
story yeah see I'm not sure if that
guy's a real guy or not because that's
kind of one where it's not super super
there's a lot of provenance for that
dudes existence okay now one guy the
prison's probably the most famous guy
associated with the lost Lost Dutchman's
mine and the reason why it's called the
Lost Dutchman's mine is this next dude
who's named Jacob waltz now they called
him the Dutchman even though he was a
German yeah because the German word for
German is Deutsche and there's a lot of
confusion with that in the unite so they
kind of called the so if they called
somebody a Dutchman that usually they
were a German yeah because they would
show up here and you know the guys
barely spoke English and they would just
say well he's he says you know he's
Deutsch he's doing she must be Dutch
yeah Dutchman okay yeah the American
English in the American vernacular was
kind of confused a lot about certain
dramatic names for things
yeah you know I mean there's a lot of
confusions in in our language about who
comes from where so I'm based on Italian
stuff too yeah which I can't remember
off the hand but I remember that a lot
of those Italian names that are in usage
here in the United States are actually
wrong yeah it's just what the guy wrote
down cuz that's what he understood
because many were coming down to LA slot
yeah they're coming through Ellis Island
and ask the guy his name he said one
thing a guy the guy right the American
guys tries to write it down he's like
yeah that's your name right
[Laughter]
so yeah Jacob waltz who actually did
exist because they have many many
records of him and like documents with
his signature on it and stuff like that
um he was a German immigrant and he had
moved to Arizona at some point this was
about in the 1870s now supposedly he was
friends with one of the heirs of the
Peralta family and they had told him
where the mine was roughly now he it
actually Walt's actually worked as a
prospector and he actually had a house
near the Superstition Mountains so this
was I guess kind of exciting for him
that somebody from the purl 2 family
told him where this mine was now he had
actually worked in a gold mined before
in Wickenburg Arizona now while he was
there again so the story goes he
supposedly met an Apache girl whose name
was Kent II now him and her started
getting busy even though he was 60 years
old and she was not much she was she was
much younger than that I don't know how
much younger but it said girl so I'm
assuming that means under 18 maybe maybe
so yeah this also might be a story yeah
but like I said this this dude did you
know he was around he has a grave he had
all they have all kind of documentation
of him although [ __ ] General Custer
was big into like 13 12 and 13 year old
you could totally get away the young
girls yeah what even seen as unusual
yeah girl a girl was supposed to be
married at around 13 so that's about so
you could pound out as many kids as Papa
where you broke and that's about you
know where Tony
eighteen hundred's and 13 is about the
age they'd be married yeah but what
they're not telling is the guys marrying
him a lot of times were 30 yeah 40
because we had a 60 like it yeah case
back then the priority was how much
money did he have yeah cuz he also paid
did things like pay dowry
well yeah so you know that was kind of
like the only consideration right how
much money how much stability and does
he move you up in the social standing
yeah that's always about yep there were
so many hookers life of freedom that's
what I mean I've generally I read a
couple books about and I came over the
name of it there was one about like a
lot of courtesans like back and you know
back in England and stuff and reading it
I was kind of like yeah I think I
probably would have done that rather
than live under the strictures that
women were put under that can back any
that those days it's like it would have
been way more fun back in those days if
you were a woman you want you would want
to be a Louisiana octoroon
okay octoroon though they were kind of
like the geisha of the United States you
had to you had to be rich to have an
octoroon mistress she lived a life of uh
basically what you kind of like a
middle-class woman of today she'd have
her own apartment
yes place wrong place she didn't have a
dude there like putting stinky socks all
over the sewer like lead pee on the
toilet seat or would know and she wasn't
married but the guy who had the contract
with her it was like a marriage he chose
her out of love and he loved her yeah
arrangement through the through the
mother the doctrine balls all right
they didn't love the life and in general
the guy didn't because he was forced
into that marriage well yeah that was
usually like setup that was a rambling
marriage with his family usually have
them do the property in order to keep
control over certain like plantations
and factories and [ __ ] that they have in
the south no they did the southern man
the rich southern manners southern man
rich southern man he was twenty thirty
trying to get married from a rich family
he couldn't choose his wife yeah the
family did
each other he could choses he could
choose this Oxford mistress though yeah
so that they actually kind of dated at
least they had a relationship and this
is there's portraits of them you can
look it up there they were gorgeous too
and some of them were women that were
Irish girls pretending to be Oxford yeah
that's another one too but well yeah why
wouldn't you right if you could get away
with it yeah I mean because that was
kind of like a little bit of a prize I
hate to use word commodity but that's me
I looked at it well the one I would then
what I read was about was actually about
England and it was kind of talking about
like Cora pearl and all your like really
famous courtesans and they were saying
like particularly into the strictures of
like Victorian England it's like these
women like I said they had these massive
they had tons of money they looks
massive apartments as these huge parties
with like always like like famous like
artists and intellectuals and stuff
would come to their parties and it was
like super super like hip like to go to
their parties and like even though they
were hookers quote-unquote it's like no
one really looked out on them because
they were kind of like they were
superstars yeah they were like the
superstars of their day yeah you had to
like you know sleep with gross ass men
but you know what I mean it's like they
had money though that was like a
probably a small price to pay in that
particular in that time another thing I
want to mention is that the word star
though you know today like oh that
person's a star that came from that
mm-hmm
in in West in western brothels in the
United States women didn't like to be
just hookers that's not really a cool
thing you know I mean they wanted to
have skills outside of that so they
learned how to sing and dance and at
those hotels they had what he called
theaters and they would sing and dance
and put on shows well they would take
that girls they would take a photo of
that girl or that girl's name and put it
inside of a star yeah outside the
theater all right so that girl's name
was in these stars they usually had more
than one star to put on a whole show all
right that way this woman could now have
little more self esteem for herself she
was an actress and an entertainer her
name was in a star
that's it literally and she could ask
for more money yeah you know and that's
where the word star came from it's just
like I said it really and reading that
book particularly about you know the
courtesans and England and stuff it
really gave you a new appreciation for
you know women at the time you know they
didn't have a lot of like choices and
what they could do and stuff like that
but these women were like entrepreneurs
really as they were open they opened
there a lot of them went on to open
their own brothels where they didn't
even have to do the dirty work
they hired other women to do it for them
there's something else for you guys if
anybody's a fan of western movies and
Old West stuff and gun fighters and [ __ ]
like if you look back into history guys
like Doc Holliday and and and the other
year Wild Bill Hickok they dated these
stars yeah that's who their girlfriends
were alright some of these gunfights
alright would go down in these towns
over those women yeah that's some weird
[ __ ] with you thank you you know he's
dating the star she's also working yeah
and he gets jealous of the Johnson have
a shootout over this prostitute but he
loves her yeah yeah a lot of that was
going on I believe they're people in all
times in all places yeah nothing changes
certain places these trick shots and gun
fighters and you know guys like you know
looking what's his name John Wesley
Hardin you know people know you need
meanest [ __ ] world shot a guy
cuz he was snoring it's actually kind of
[ __ ] do it do when he got it he
killed a lot of dudes but it was in
self-defense he got out he became a
lawyer
he was only dead about a year in jail I
became a lawyer and they did the same
kind of stuff you know I mean if a woman
wasn't married then there must been
something wrong with her
yeah I mean yeah so if you were a single
guy there was really no such thing as
dating chances were it was gonna be you
were gonna be hanging out with a star
yeah
well it's not like you had a lot of
options Fabian yeah it's not like
nowadays were you just like date people
it's normal well I can't have that
no because like like you said all the
married ones they usually arranged them
and like you couldn't they're married or
they were old ladies yeah you know the
only available young women we're stars
yeah maybe Indian women yeah yeah so you
you know human nature being what it is
that's how shits gonna go down yeah cuz
you know like finds a ways old I have an
alien that whole Mandan tribe went
extinct because everybody married
they're women yeah that's how the story
goes I don't know if it's true I've
heard that story and evidently they
would they'd like the most beautiful or
the most beautiful Indian women are up
near Northeast somewhere and evidently
every one of them got married off to a
white guy who gave a huge dowry doesn't
do mile the dudes in the tribe are like
what the [ __ ] well well they were might
have been going out with you know other
Indian women yeah so but doesn't take
long to upset the balance of a
reproductive system yeah I mean all you
have to do is take a couple generations
away and that's it yeah you know and
these may be that tribal in that big to
begin with but they really they had all
songs about Mandan Indians they were
doing the best look it was or at least
somebody thought that at least the
person that read this it's legendary
stories yeah the West yeah so uh again
going back to another legendary story of
the West so as I said Jacob waltz he
apparently marries well I don't know if
he married her but like you know they
were together this much younger Apache
girl named Kent II now shortly after
this happened Walt's got fired from his
job at the vulture gold mine in
Wickenburg Arizona because he was doing
what they call high grading the or
meaning when he found the or he would
just pocket the good [ __ ] and they just
like hey I just know this kind of like
so he was stealing essentially
so you know they let him go and then him
and Ken team moved to the Superstition
Mountains now there are two versions of
this story one version says that he
found out where the mine was from a
member of the Peralta family that he
knew another version of the story says
that Ken T who was Apache that she told
him so I don't know but he supposedly
found out in one way or another now in
the version of the story where Ken T
told him when they actually went there
looking for it the Apache saw her and
took her like kidnapped her and copper
tongue out way in retaliation because
she wasn't supposed to tell anybody
where it was sounds like a story so I
don't like I said I don't know sounds
like a story I don't know because if she
already told that what good would it be
to cut the tongue out I guess they were
just punishing her here just like this
got you in trouble so we're just getting
rid of this you can't get any more
trouble but supposedly after that
happened Walt's got away and he went and
opened a saloon apparently not to worse
for wear now in 1877 he meets this other
guy again who may or may not be
fictional I'm not real sure he's either
called Jacob wiser or Jacob Wisner I've
seen it spelled both ways so then they
go into the superstitions looking for
this mine now
not too long after they went in there
they started to come out and they and
people started to notice that they were
coming into Phoenix like paying for
things with gold ore and it was real
good [ __ ] too so they never like filed a
claim for a mine or anything like that
so like you know as [ __ ] does back then
when you come into a store and you're
like paying for stuff with like really
good [ __ ] people like I wonder where he
got that from so like stories start
going around now a couple years after
that apparently Waltz's partner his
partner who i don't know if he exists or
not
he apparently disappeared without a
trace now some people said that waltz
killed them
some people said the Apaches killed him
so whether he existed or not I don't
know if he did he disappeared and
somebody killed him they think so
could have been either one of them
although somebody could disappear for
many different reasons back then true
that so it could have just not been
anything nefarious whatever although
considering all the sketchy [ __ ] that
went down or all these gold mines it was
probably the favorite these [ __ ]
killed each other like well they did it
cuz you could yeah it's like you could
get away with it back if you found a
[ __ ] gold thing and like people were
trying to like infringe on your [ __ ] man
they would just like blow your head off
they don't care yeah but I would assume
back in those days there were dudes that
had killed kills that were you know
rivaled the the numbers of kills of like
serial killers oh I'm sure I'm sure that
you know there was that there were guys
out there they killed over a hundred
people oh there must have been there was
a boy in a big deal because yeah like I
said we they didn't look at it the same
way because there was so much I mean it
was a lot of places were still kind of
lawless yeah it's like there was this
something talking about yeah like I said
there was this whole thing about like
gold mines it's like you know if he
didn't stake your claim on he had to
like protect it look like people came
and tried to steal your [ __ ] then you
had to like well there's probably a lot
of guys that would kind of befriend
somebody else now we're time to say you
didn't like him and they're out there in
the field together and just kills that
dude in his sleep take him off a cliff
ya know takes all his [ __ ] yeah I mean
and then move happened you're right yeah
moves on like nothin even half as pawns
off his stuff you know make a living
doing that you know those guys in India
you know whether the thuggy yeah we're
basically did that like I live in
stealing and killing particularly back
in the Old West it's not like yeah it's
not like you're really gonna get mean
you know you could get away with a lot
back that we're about DNA back then yeah
exactly this response to yeah you may
have like licked fingerprinting or
anything I really know police response
time or anything
now we're no witnesses he'd never get
caught yeah nobody sitting even if there
were yeah you can just kill the
witnesses it's like well what's one more
yeah so after that after his uh you know
possibly fictional partner disappeared
so over the next decade
Jacob Walt starts turning up in Phoenix
like buying supplies and things like
that and he would have like saddlebags
full of like really good gold ore and
then he would you know get his stuff and
then he would take off back into the
Superstition Mountains again so people
like where the [ __ ] is he getting all
this gold from there must be like this
really kick ass like mine in the
Superstition Mountains somewhere so they
start asking him about it and like a
smart person he tells everybody
different [ __ ] or he tells him like
contradictions I can't tell why the [ __ ]
would you tell anybody where it is
they're just gonna kill you and like
take your [ __ ] you know what I mean so
you know and sometimes he'd be like oh
yeah come on I'll show you and then like
they'd follow him and then like he would
give him the slip and so like I said he
was obviously not a dummy now in 1891
apparently uh Waltz's house which was
right near the Superstition Mountains
was actually destroyed in a flood now he
was saved by two brothers whose names
were Herman and Reinhardt pet rash and
he also was taken care of by a woman
named Julia Thomas who I guess was a
nurse and but he had you know during the
flood and the storm everything like that
he had gotten pneumonia and he thought
that he was probably gonna die so he
sent friends back to his house which was
now just kind of like rubble because the
flood and everything he said I had some
gold like kind of stashed under the
floorboards or whatever so go see if you
can find that so his friends go there
and the house was gone the flood had
swept it away but they did find five
sacks with gold in it and this was worth
about fifteen thousand dollars I'm
guessing in back then money which was
like a huge huge amount so they brought
it back to him because he's like the
honest most honest dudes in the Old West
I know so they always say they bring his
like here's your stuff man and they put
it under his sickbed now apparently
while he was in this final illness and
while this Julia Thomas woman was around
he supposedly would like go in and out
of like he be feverish and stuff and he
would like supposedly give clues to
where this mine was but why they were
asking him I guess they probably were
they like he's gonna die soon come on
like tell maybe it'll says write it down
write it down I might mean something so
so apparently he's giving him clues the
whole time even though like I said if he
was like so appreciative and he thought
he was gonna die and stuff you think he
would just tell him all outright like
where exactly it was instead of being
all [ __ ] cagey about it unless he was
just a dick and he just I'm suspicious I
am too kind of yeah I mean I don't know
like like I said this dude did exist and
I mean there are a lot of stories of him
like coming into Phoenix and having a
bunch of gold and stuff like that so he
did get that gold from somewhere yeah
they're just not sure if it actually
came from the place where it was
supposed to have come from but so
eventually he gets sicker and sicker
then he gets a stroke and he has a
stroke and then he's like paralyzed he
can't really talk anymore now even
before he died Julia and the two
brothers they decide we're gonna go into
the superstitions and see if we can find
her so that's you know from all the
clues that he'd been talking about so
they were there for five weeks on their
expedition but didn't find anything now
Jacob waltz died in October of 1891 and
after that point like after his death
and then you know after all the legends
around started kind of like seeping into
the public consciousness that's when
they started calling it the Lost
Dutchman mine even though like I said
he's a German so Julia Thomas like I
said she had gone this one expedition
that lasted five weeks they didn't find
anything and she had kind of sunk all
her money into it and it was not
fruitful so she never went back out
there now the two brothers that had
saved him from the fly
apparently they got into like some kind
of snippy little arguments because it's
like well you should have like listened
more to what Jacob waltz was saying when
he was dying and maybe he gave us a clue
and you didn't write it down right or
something like that Stig in this big
fight then they never like spoke again
like so that was like some big fight
that they had and both of them actually
start went many times the Superstition
Mountains like separately like on
separate expeditions looking for it but
of course they never found anything
either
now over the years since then many many
people have gone looking for it and so
far none have been successful although I
should say that I was on one website
today and I think it was just called
Lost Dutchman mine calm or something
like that and they said that they'd
found it but I'm like skimming through
there and I'm like hmm I don't know
there's like there's so many things
that's people that say that they found
it they said they found what they have
photographs I don't know they have
photographs of something brother I just
think that a mind is a mind that's guys
yes did you find it goes somewhere it's
big yeah that's what a mine is yeah I
kind of feel like every time somebody
announced that they found it I think
it's just like they were sitting on
their couch and they think they figured
out a new that everywhere was right man
there it is I don't have the money to go
look I kind of feel like that might be
what a situation is not how it works
yeah so as I said over the years you
know the curse and the legend continues
to grow because you know so many
mysterious deaths and everything now a
few more of the stories that happened
like after the death of Jacob waltz
summer of 1882 guys they had been
soldiers they were recently discharged
from Fort McDowell they show up in
Pinole Arizona at the Silver King mine
they're looking for employment there now
they showed and they had a bag of gold
ore and they showed it to the manager
and it was like really good [ __ ] like I
said and he asked him where the hell did
you get that and he said oh well we
found it while we were
saying Superstition Mountain and we saw
an old mine while we were passing
through there so the manager of this
particular mine the Silver King was like
well okay that sounds like something I
want to get involved in so he bought the
gold and not only bought the gold ore
from the two guys but he also um like
gave them some money to you know buy
supplies and stuff so they could go back
out there like all three of them could
go back out there so the two guys were
like yeah we totally remember where that
[ __ ] is yeah like guys do yeah so the
two guys go out there we go yeah we
totally know where that is they go out
there heading toward weavers needle and
they never return so they're gone for
two weeks and finally the managers like
where the [ __ ] did they go so he sends a
search party out after them he finds
their nude bodies and both of them had
been shot in the head doesn't make sense
the story why did they say they were
going back to the mind because this this
other guy like this manager this other
mind like gave him a bunch of money and
was like got into partnership with them
and said okay when they check the third
guy I don't know if they took the third
again it's not like a good dad I don't
like your cellphone's ago here it is
yeah that didn't sound right he would
think that he would that he would want
want them to take them back to the mine
you know like yeah take me back to that
mine that's what I thought was weird
it's like why didn't the third guy go
with them because then saundra he could
have just like giving him a bunch of
money for supplies and [ __ ] and then
they'd be like yeah we're gonna go to
the - we have some gold back bye
yeah but uh you know this is a that
story sounds fishy to me yeah so summit
like I said some of these sound
believable and some of them sound fishy
like so like people do go there looking
for the [ __ ] and they do die and they do
find their skeletons later on and they
have found some skulls with like bullet
holes and image it yeah so somebody's
murdering people out there right but
where's the mine right yeah I don't know
no one's ever found it it's just like
that Oak Island [ __ ] man you got any
more stories yeah there's a few more
okay so why what are we at brilliant we
only had 30 minutes to
it's why he turned up you trying to rush
me no okay I'm say we got time yeah all
right so the year after that there was
this other guy he was a prospector his
name was Joe Dearing now he had been
working as a bartender um and he heard
the stories about this - guys like
turning up dead around the money he's
like well I'm trying to go look for that
my own self now he coat he goes out
there or so he tells everybody and then
when he comes back he said that he found
it he described it quote-unquote as the
most god-awful rough place you can
imagine and he also called it quote
unquote a ghostly place now he started
he was still working as a bartender and
he started saving up money like to go
out there for a full excavation because
he only just went like to look for the
location apparently he didn't like blow
anything up or nothing so he also worked
at the same mine as the guy from the
previous story the silver King mine and
he went to work there for extra money
and then it turned out that a week after
he started working at that mine for
extra money to go back into the
superstitions he got killed in a cave-in
so there's that curse again do we know
these are real people some of them are
yeah well okay some of them are because
they have records of them like there are
records of these people do enough to
store that where the story is verified
do we know that or they just some of
them like some of them yeah but like
some of them are you know have been just
there's a couple things in that story
that kind of stick out to me yeah
come specs is all I know where it is boy
it's in a rough place you know it's
terrible yeah no well that that right
there is kind of like a sideways excuse
you say I found it other people couldn't
find it because it's really rough to get
in there yeah
that's why other people aren't fine and
that's why people can't find this thing
but not really because what you do is
you find the roughest place you can find
on the map and that's where it is yeah
it sounds like a story to me well here's
the thing if I like not that I'm gonna
do this right there was if there was a
mine that was hidden it's more likely
that it's in it
totally nondescript place that has no
description and doesn't stick out at all
well yeah you know because if it was
somewhere easy like Oh in the shadow of
weavers needle you think Roy billions of
people would have found it by now
because that's like that's a specific
place but if it's a hole in the ground
in a flat plane somewhere it's hard to
describe that and you wouldn't be
attracted yeah if there are no landmarks
they'll drag marks around everything so
that last one about being in a really
rough place and boy whoo yeah I'm not
buying that thank because you would
because a place like that would stick
out and would be checked yeah yeah well
yeah like I said anything with like any
kind of like yeah stand out land money
in a unit any unusual features would be
checked because it attracts your
attention yeah so that means over time
if this mine wasn't found it wasn't
found because it's in a place that is
unremarkable yeah if it's there if it's
there it's gonna be in a place that is
unremarkable didn't know what even
thought it's right that's what I'm
thinking cuz just statistically that's
probably a good point because another
thing too is like I always feel like
especially back in the old gold
prospecting days considering how
competitive that [ __ ] [ __ ] was it's
like if you were out there in the
mountains and you came across like a
super rich like vein of gold or
something like that I would not tell
anybody about that mines there I think
it's in a place that is very nondescript
it doesn't have any terrain features
around it and you'd have to stumble upon
it by pure luck by pure chance in other
words it's in the middle of flat open
ground somewhere yeah and maybe because
of you know for one reason or another
there's a it's just a hole that goes
straight down to the ground yeah you
know but I can't I can't imagine if I
can mine looking like that
you know I mean mine usually has to have
tracks or up or a structure to hold it
up because you know mean as you're
digging you're trying to stop cave-ins
and stuff you don't I mean yeah it's
usually not something that just goes
straight down into the ground unless
it's just an open pit mine somebody's
just dig it you know
yeah but it's just is this sounds fishy
to me
well yeah and like I said a lot of these
sound fishy because it seems like a lot
of the dudes that go in there and then
they come back out going yeah I found
that [ __ ] why the [ __ ] would you come
out of the mountains ago yeah I totally
found it I'm like you're just
practically begging back just
particularly back in those days bragging
again you're begging to get killed or
tortured for something where the [ __ ] is
it I like I said I would keep mum about
that [ __ ] and you know mine is something
this dog we're not talking a cave yeah I
mean so I don't know like I think when
they say Lost Dutchman mine I think
they're talking about like a natural the
time when I'm natural mind like a cage
yeah like a natural mind or like a
natural gold vein like a really rich
gold vein I don't think they're talking
about a mind like a man-made mine
because that nobody says I mean nowadays
like when people go out there looking
for it it's like they go out there were
dynamite and all this other kind of [ __ ]
but I don't think that they mean like
okay it was a man-made mine I think they
mean it's like a natural okay I was
think I was aiming that they were
talking about like an abandoned they're
just they just call it that man once a
man-made mine they got a band
okay yeah I think they're just talking
about like so much of the place where
this gold is yeah I think then you
recognize it that's what I mean I think
they just ended up calling it that
because that was the easiest thing to
call it and then he's like oh I know
where it is
yeah I'm sure you do where's the gold
yeah like I said why the [ __ ] would you
say that well why they even if you did
even if you did find it why would you
tell anybody I wouldn't tell any song
that you'd think he'd knock some gold
out of the wall right put it in a bag
and bring it with you cash in the keys
couldn't find it again right well yeah
that'd be the first thing you would read
well I get as much as you could get and
they're right and I mean even then like
I'd be scared like you go into town and
like you cash it in everybody like
where'd you get that oh I don't know I
just found it yeah it was just laying
around
I think anybody I think anybody's
showing up saying I know where it is and
they don't have gold in their hands I
wouldn't believe it
yeah well they're showing off now the
other guy the other guys who had gold
and get in sold it to the other mine it
was in a bag
yeah so
means that they just found a bag of gold
they found a bag of gold or they could
have bought it from someone else or
there's a lot of possibilities in that
situation they didn't necessarily have
to say they knew where the mine was
right yeah there's a lot of other places
you could get gold okay okay so here's
another story and this one is about a
prospector whose name was Alicia Marcus
Revis and they called him the madman of
the superstitions okay
now this guy I mean eventually I guess
like before he had been like a
schoolteacher so he was like college
educated and everything like that but he
um he had actually started out like I
said he was teaching but then during the
gold rush he went out to California and
like started looking for gold but he
didn't really find any of anything out
there so in the 1860s he moved to
Arizona and he was kind of living out in
the mountains and he kind of turned into
like you know he had the patented like
Old Testament hermit kind of thing
they're all worth like the big old beard
and like he was a king Jeremiah Johnson
Johnston yeah yeah we need to do a show
about Jeremiah Johnson I thought did we
are we were just talking about that
talking about cuz I remember we were
talking about doing it that was a long
time ago then I thought we had done it
but I guess we didn't do one did we
the legendary Jeremiah Johnson we
probably should liver-eating Johnson
yeah that's what they called him
I can only I can only hope that one day
I don't think yeah I think we were
talking about doing a show about that so
yeah so apparently this guy like I said
he had the whole hermit thing going he
had like the big beard he would run
around naked in the mountains and like
fire his gun in this guy and show like
that um also but this had the added
benefit maybe this is why I was doing I
don't know that apparently the Apache
were kind of scared of him because they
said okay so so they kind of left him
alone so there was there was a plus in
that situation so um alright so again he
lived like kind of around the
Superstition Mountains and I don't know
if he knew where the mine was but you
know he did talk about it at some point
with
did find him in 1896
I guess his friends said Heyward that
crazy hermit guy go and they go in there
to look for him and then they found him
about four miles south of his house like
in this on a trail near Rogers Canyon
and his head had been cut off so again
yeah so I guess the Apaches got guys
yeah catch you a [ __ ] head off
I guess so that's some bad [ __ ] we cut
my fingers you must be pretty mad when
you do that uh yeah I've always been
kind of like I've always been fascinated
by like decapitation in a weird kind of
way
no like I was reading this one thing cuz
when I was growing up I read about you
know Mary Queen of Scots and she got
beat when she got beheaded and the story
I heard I don't know how true this is
but the story I heard was that when they
went to behead her because then before
they had the guillotine and all that
they just had to do it with [ __ ] axe
which you know might not have been all
that jarrah blunt yeah yeah they're
pretty blunt so apparently she's had a
she went outside she was like inside she
had like a red dress on her everything
and apparently the executioner like kind
of missed the first like he didn't miss
miss but he missed like cutting her head
off so it's like he just kind of like
chunked into her shoulder or something
like that cuz I don't know I guess he'd
been like drinking the night before or
whatever and um so but it didn't kill
her and I was like that when I was a kid
that [ __ ] horrified me because I'm
like can you imagine it's bad enough
that you're like laying there with your
head on a plot on a block waiting
knowing that you're gonna get your head
chopped off in a second and then like
you just think okay you're gonna get it
over with and then it didn't do it then
he hasn't like do it again you ever seen
a video beheading yeah I've seen it too
how were Saudi Arabia there and
beheading people during those days it's
horrifying they do a lot of screaming
ahead one where there this girl this
woman was accused of killing and she was
like a nanny accused of killing the baby
because she was watching I don't know
all the details but she was begging for
mercy trying to run from this guy and
they were hold her down they left kind
of sympathetic they didn't look like
they wanted to do it they took her head
off for that damn Arabic sword and what
was funny is it didn't take much
strength
that that sword must have been super
sharp could you see he just went like it
was like a little [ __ ] hit you that her
head attached as her head just came
right off stringently as well yeah I
didn't believe I was expecting him to
like really bow up and put a [ __ ]
samurais slice into it now it's just
kind of like chopped into that blade
maybe move four feet move three feet
that's horrible
- and her head which to me that's just
like seeing like that and getting eaten
by a shark or like some of the worst
things I can think I look pretty quick
to me yeah but see the thing is sucked
is that she was trying to roll away from
it go no no no no holding her down you
know that I can you imagine you can eyes
and knowing that that's gonna happen
yeah yeah he's trying to cheat trying to
get away she's got that damn veil on you
know that what's that thing that they
wear yeah you know she's got that on
he's trying to figure out where the neck
is not any funny and it just rolls right
off
yikes yeah well and also you know for a
long time especially you know before
right before and after they invented the
guillotine yeah they were like super
into like doing all these experiments to
see how long your head would live like
after it got cut off
it doesn't live yeah and I I'm kind of
like you know it's not like you can like
do an experiment on that like ethically
let's cut off people's heads and yeah
like hey how many fingers am i holding
up like that's horrible but it's like it
did look like people's eyes and she like
reacting here for at least like 20
seconds or such a long time wasn't it
like 20 seconds 30 seconds and yeah but
it takes a long long enough it takes a
long time for the brain to starve of
oxygen so chances are they could be kind
of semi-conscious for God wouldn't be
horrible it's probably several minutes
but I think I think the trauma the
psychological trauma I would hope that
being beheaded causes you to pass out I
think and also you got understand the
blood pressure would [ __ ] would drive
drive instantly so I'm not sure if you
could maintain like consciousness like
for very long not full consciousness
maybe few seconds
that says that kind of [ __ ] gives me
[ __ ] nightmares even like five
seconds if like realizing that you were
just ahead would be just like god that'd
be the [ __ ] work yeah you take the
head you show up the body look right I
know that's what I mean oh [ __ ]
horrible like that story about Mary
Queen of Scots a little scene from The
Omen where [ __ ] David Warner gets his
head chopped off with a pane of glass
it's like even though it looks kind of
fakie now and stuff like that oh that
traumatized they said yeah evidently
that one gun yeah I also kind of funny
that one doctor bragging to the best
account I've heard was there was a
French doctor who at the guillotine
reached down to today into the bath he
did it basket got the head yeah and he
said the eyes were closed yeah but he
called the guy's name and the eyes and
the eyes opened and looked at him and he
made yeah I remember he made eye contact
with him for a second but then the eyes
closed again we're just talking about
like gold mines in this now we're
talking about like [ __ ] heads
yeah yeah alright so let me see let's
see if I have any more stories about
people that won't look over this [ __ ]
okay so um 1900 okay they were newer
yeah so there were two more yeah like
kind of the most famous you know one
that kind of cemented in the public
consciousness actually didn't have until
the 30s but yeah so it's about 1900
there's two prospectors their names were
mom and silver Locke and they started
working around the northern edge of
Superstition Mountain they found a
little bit of gold but not so much in
the mountain itself I think I heard that
they found like some little leftover
nuggets from when the Peralta family was
massacred like what way all that all
those years ago you know cuz like I said
when the Apaches killed them and like
kind of the gold got scattered
everywhere
so they apparently found some of that
but didn't really find that much in the
mountain so 1910
mom turns up in Mesa Arizona and tells
everything this partner silver Locke was
trying to kill him and then silver Locke
gets arrested he gets and then he gets
an insanity plea like they call him
insane they sent him to like some poor
farmer like some [ __ ] asylum or
something like that and then both of
them later died now also in that same
year they actually found a skeleton of a
woman and this was in a cave like way up
on in the mountain and next to the body
they found like a whole bunch of gold
nuggets now they said I don't know they
could tell this but they said her death
was fairly recent but they couldn't tell
where the goals had come from or how she
had died or anything so I don't know if
she actually found some gold in the
mountain then where she died next to
some nuggets or she just chicken nuggets
she died next to a pilot again we're so
silly
now another story goes that in 1927
there was a guy from New Jersey and his
sons and they were hiking through the
Superstition Mountains
when boulders started rolling down on
them from looks like someone was pushing
boulders down on them you know it means
so this was 1927 so I don't know it was
like still Apaches up there and my story
pushing rocks down or anything like that
yeah
probably like I said there's a lot of
stories about these mountains they don't
call them superstitions for nothing
right so now what rolling out in
California alright Sierra Nevada
mountains as a kid a lot of ravines and
crevices and [ __ ] like that you know we
always have this innate fear of boulders
boulders are a meme you know what I mean
but in reality we walked around all day
long and no boulders ever [ __ ] came
down on us
bobert boulders are a meme I would have
thought that you probably would have got
that more from
Looney Tunes cartoon yeah like that's
where it comes from the coyote like you
as you try to push him down on the ridge
and boulders all time boulders are
mostly a meme you don't just walk around
and get hit by boulders well who could
even like put its no one could push a
boulder it's a baby but they do fall off
I guess you can push a boulder because
it's on a slope to begin with you know
and we may not be talking about a big
boulder you know we're like it's a big I
guess Boulder then have to be that big
doesn't weigh that big yeah doesn't have
to be a Wyatt as high or just so little
and squishable well we're not talking
about a wily coyote something us you
know five feet diameter you know you can
push that down the side of the hill
usually it's connected to something but
if you push on and it'll fall yeah but
half the time we used to play with them
they were just more like dried big old
hard pack mud things and as they rolled
they got smaller break it up yeah did
you ever are quote boulders
did you ever push one off of a cliff
yeah yeah did you kill anybody
no no how do you know cuz cuz we were
kids we couldn't get up on a high cliff
we're talking about you know I'm in a
cliff that was only maybe thirty feet
tall or you know cuz when Nephi shitty
if you were just like kids and you're
playing up and you like knocked a
boulder off and then you know they're
just like killing a [ __ ]
wherever those boulders were there
wasn't anything that they could get hurt
you know and I mean you weren't around
roads or anything playing around inside
the Mojave Desert [ __ ] you know camping
yeah that kind of stuff blowing [ __ ] up
blow [ __ ] up lizards with the BB gun you
did not she's killing them too don't
kill the lizard thing kid you know what
I mean you're supposed to kill lizards
back then no there's a BB guns are for
contagious like shot shoot him and they
jump up in here and hit the ground it
hit the ground stiff as a board you know
vibrating Wow from it had a dog with me
then a doggy Needham yeah yeah dog to
eat him up totally some good came yeah
dog eat eat the [ __ ] out of it
I adore the timing I mean I guess who
Carol Isaac is like Pookie kills Liz
yeah we try to like keep her from doing
it yes okay you know what her latest
thing is check this [ __ ] out she's our
kitty is like a genius so well for she's
a kitty yeah yeah well what she does is
like when she goes out in the back porch
like we trying to get her not to play
with lizards because she doesn't try to
kill him she kills him with him but she
ends up killing him just because she's
like you know paano chick so but what
she's trying to do now since Tom always
takes the lizard's away from her yells
at her so she tries to bring him inside
to play with but she knows that Tom
doesn't want her to bring them inside so
what she started doing now is like
she'll hide it in her mouth she'll like
stick it in her mouth and then like
she'll clone the door like oh my god let
me in let me in let me in and then you
let her in and then she runs like really
fast like out of the room and like into
and then she goes and hides yeah because
she knows that if we see that she has a
lizard they'll be take it away you gotta
check that mouth so as soon if she comes
in and like jaws you got a chaser and be
like what's in your mouth because she
always she's she's super snake fighting
is defining lizards in the house dead
lizards in the house yeah another day I
got up and she was like sitting out in
the out in the front room and she was
sitting there looking at me and she had
her pawn or dead lizards like that like
look fatted yeah I got this [ __ ] in here
and yelled even say yeah you got it
she'll kill those tree frogs - yeah we
found many dead frogs in the house
that's like really whoa
oh no I forgot that that's girl was that
her or what that might have been the
bigger cat you don't know she'll body
slam squirrels yeah we found a headless
squirrel on the porch one night yeah
Beijing Beijing ate the 8:8 that
squirrel eventually yeah like she threw
it up
yeah she did I mean she's she's brought
us like moles and stuff but I think that
was like the first time moles and
Gophers and Gophers yeah but that was
the first time I'd ever seen a squirrel
and like that bring her bring us girl
and first time that it didn't
have a head it was like it was guts
hanging every baby cookie was braggin
trying to trying to convince me she kill
she was trying to claim the kid yeah I
don't think that she killed that's
course she's like looked at me like she
can't pick it up body yeah that's I mean
she's really smart she's she's smart
enough to like try to deceive us yeah I
think she killed that squirrel probably
like I said baby cookie seems like she's
not much bigger than a squirrel herself
yeah no I said she's not a large rabbit
yeah she said she's small for a cat
though yeah she's uh banks though yeah I
think the wool they don't get big for
five you five years I don't they don't
get to full size until five years and
she's only two alright let's get back to
the show you stupid getting bortles
everybody's talking about the kiddies
okay all right so now probably the event
that cemented the Lost Dutchman mine
into American public consciousness and
it's like the legendary status that it
has today happened in 1931 and this
dealt with a dude named Adolf Ruth who
was a veterinarian from Washington DC
and he also had a side hustle like
looking for treasure so now he
supposedly had a map now his son had
supposedly got this map in Mexico
several years before and it supposedly
came from the time of the Mexican
Revolution they later called this the
Ruth Peralta map so he was actually
looking for the Peralta minds that the
Peralta family had had that like I said
they had a gold mine except those silver
mines so um and also the Lost Dutchman
mine because those might have been two
separate things so he supposedly had
this map that he had so he goes there in
in May of 1931 and he gets like a couple
of guides and they go around in the
summer and they go into the mountains
looking for the [ __ ] now they don't hear
anything from Adolph Ruth for six days
and so someone goes out looking for him
who was like you know the guide the
guide people's he sent like two Cowboys
out there like that were guide so that
that dude the boss like went out looking
for them so they go out and they find a
camp but they don't find anyone at it so
they report they reported missing and
they keep looking around for the next
like month and a half or something like
them they don't find anything now in
December of nineteen thirty one they
find a skull with two holes in it and
this was later determined to belong to
Adolph Ruth hmm now they didn't find the
rest of him until about a month later
and that was like in a little river they
found the rest of his body but they also
found his treasure map and it was still
at his campsite so like no one had taken
it or anything so they're not entirely
sure he was killed away from his camp he
was killed away from his he wasn't
robbed he was killed just for being
where he was yeah so I don't think that
you ever is again 1931 okay
shot twice in the head it looked like um
you know ran afoul I guess so
and somebody beheaded him well like I
said it didn't see either that or I mean
I guess because the body in the head
were found so far apart because I was
gonna say I was scattered by animals but
I think that was such a big thing
beheading yeah is it such a big distance
it sounds like a beheading now um so all
this stuff that came out in the
newspapers about it of course like made
this big deal but oh he got murdered for
the map and you know he really knew
where the mine was and all this other
kind of [ __ ] um but there was uh there
was also some speculation about oh maybe
he wasn't murdered like maybe those
weren't actually bullet holes although
like I said how does his head and body
get so far apart unless somebody
murdered him seriously and like what
else are those big two holes gonna be
like if you just fell off a mountain or
something it's not holes it's you know
it's all busted up it's not like you
know I mean he was [ __ ] I feel like he
is probably shot and beheaded like I
said yeah so you know there we go well
like I said he said he had a map for it
but I don't think that the bird did that
man obviously because they didn't take
it
they still found it that it was back in
seems like he may have been killed I
think was unrelated to him looking for
that treasure exactly so you know as I
said that was kind of like the one that
like I said cemented the legend into the
Americans since that time many many many
many many many people have gone into the
Superstition Mountains looking for the
Lost Dutchman mine some have not
returned some had been found later in
skeletal form but as of today no one has
found this mine no one has found any
gold in the Superstition Mountains there
has been like I said there were gold
mines around there and [ __ ] like that
but like I said a lot of experts say
that if there is a mine there it's not
in the superstitions because it's not
the kind or if it's if there's gold
there it's not in Super students because
not the right kind of rock so what do
you think Jane honestly I probably think
like I said there have been gold mines
around that similar area but as far as
the iconic Lost Dutchman gold mined the
one in the Superstition Mountain like
there supposedly this really rich vein I
don't think it's there I'm a [ __ ] I
mean it's possible obviously because
it's a big place and it's like yeah
people have been looking for it for you
know decades and decades like you know
since since Jacob well it's supposedly
found gold there but you think someone
would have come off something but in
this modern era of GPS and [ __ ]
internal combustion engines and
four-wheelers and three wheelers but can
Park Rangers and just just over this
amount of time it would have been found
this this is a legend and I'm gonna see
there based on a lie or misunderstanding
probably a lie somebody had some gold
and then they lied about where they got
it
that's probably what started this I kind
of feel like that might have been the
issue and that might have been what
Walt's was doing cuz like I said you
know I don't know if this is legend or
not but the dude did exist it's like
apparently he did come into Phoenix and
he had a bunch of really high-grade ore
that he was paying for [ __ ] with but did
he get that from the Superstition
Mountain me got that off he might have
got it somewhere else he might have
gotten that from
but from from somebody else that he had
killed right and that's what I made that
story up
oh well yeah cuz that's a better story -
build a good dude - kill this dude and
took his gold yeah he got in California
you know yeah probably what it was
somebody somebody got it out of cow head
out of California during the gold rush
killed that dude on the road and took
that [ __ ] and made up story where he
found it and that's more like the thing
about a lot of these gold mines - and
like they I think they mentioned this a
little bit on the in search of show that
I was watching was that it particularly
during the gold rush
it's like towns would you know if
somebody found a vein of gold somehow
its Frank town would spring up like
overnight already notch and there'd be
like 10 20,000 people there suddenly
yeah and then when it dried up and we
years later yeah and then like the whole
thing would be gone it's a ghost town
it'd be called a ghost town and there's
only one of them still surviving there's
a ghost town that in fact they found out
there in California I think was
California and it's now a national park
good there's one in Arizona around here
too it's called gold field is there yeah
there was one of them that was found
kind of recently like in the 60s I think
if memory serves invited mine they found
her like man look at this this is a town
yeah and it was a gold rush - who knew
and it was just sitting out there by
itself by itself you know weren't any
roads modern roads weren't connected to
it
I can't really remember I think it was
found in the 50s or the 60s I think I
know what you're talkin about cuz didn't
we see something about that like yeah
and it's intact
that's pretty it is intact it had
furniture in it it's not very big but it
had furniture in it and glass windows
and everything but you can go tour it
now yeah you know that the port the Park
Service took over it same thing with
superstition and like I said as far as I
know the town of Goldfield which is a
ghost town now - in Arizona which is not
far from the Superstition Mountains as
far as I knew they've made a national
park out of all of that like you can
tour it and stuff but you're technically
not allowed to go treasure-hunting there
although some people still yeah on the
sly because some people are just
convinced that there's got to be gold
out there somewhere because like I said
some people have come back for
there with gold and claimed that that's
where they found it yeah it's time it's
possible go sure that's a good that's
it's an American phenomenon town appear
out of nowhere run for about three or
four years and then run out of money and
vanish yep there's no reason to go there
well yeah because once like I said the
whole reason it was there because
somebody found gold like in an area and
everybody's gonna go look for it or they
or I think in some quite cases they
claimed they found gold there and yeah
that's did a bunch of mine there was no
gold and then there was an na and two
three years later people just left yeah
it's just or sometimes they did find
gold and they'd be like oh this big rich
vein but it ran out it was so you know I
feel like that might have been a case
here it's I feel like but it because
this after the story took over like
after Jacob waltz died and after this
whole thing about the map and all that
other kind of stuff I just I just feel
like the story kind of took on a life of
its own
so maybe dude did find gold there or
somewhere around there but and like I
said you know it's possible that there
could be gold around there because you
know the Apache had legends about gold
being in the mountains even like way
before that happened like he before the
Spaniards got there but I think the
legend was solidified when somebody
showed up with gold saying I got it out
of there and that pay me for this gold
but that's not where that gold came from
maybe not
he stole the gold or killed somebody for
the gold or you know got it at a very
remote location and didn't want to say
where it was yeah then that started this
cycle of lying about this gold and
something that I found about you there
is no gold in those mountains there
might not be like I said because it's
not the right kind of rock but um
something that is interesting to me
about a lot of these legends and I think
and I can't remember what subject we
were talking about but there was another
thing that happened with this was that
sometimes if a story about a place
develops like later on like sometimes
[ __ ] happen before that will be
dated to like fit into the modern story
you know me so I don't know if that's
the case here because maybe there's the
whole thing about Jacob waltz and he
came out of the Superstition Mountains
of gold and then they kind of backdated
it to say oh the Apache had all this all
these stories about gold in there and
the Spaniards and all this other kind of
stuff so I don't know that's not buying
it because the Apaches knew that gold
was valuable they knew all about gold
yeah those Apaches would've been all
over that area and they'd have that gold
in their hands be trading guns for it
well think yeah yeah if there was gold
there the badges window every time I
read about like gold prospectors and
stuff like that I can't help but hear
like you somebody Sam's boys going go
yeah do any Linney teens cartoons and I
was grown up and all of these all of
these stories kind of hands-on the fact
that the Indians didn't value gold total
[ __ ] the Indians got valued gold
yeah that they would just leave it where
you go they did Gold was money Indians
too understood what money was well yeah
like I said they weren't dumb like this
wasn't the 1500s yes the 1800s and 1700
they knew what goal was yeah I kind of
feel like there's probably you know what
I mean that's I just kind of feel like
there's nothing there I know that I
understand like the kind of magic of
like these people that like to go
treasure not just for gold mines but
that go looking for like pirate wrecks
and stuff like that because I don't know
I it's the same thing that like keeps
people gambling I guess it's like you
know you're probably not gonna win but
if you luck out it's like gonna be this
big deal the thing is though if you if
you go looking for gold in the
Superstition Mountains that's owned by
the government now so even if found
anything you can keep it yeah so why
bother looking plus it's like really
inhospitable territory to go looking for
gold it's probably better to go memory
searches in the modern era they've been
all kinds of guys so I can trying to
find the gold and then you actually go
I'm looking for it it's a park now they
even allowed to go walking around there
now you I think you can go walking
around but like you're not allowed to go
in there like we're gonna found by now
it's there's no gold there I don't think
there is a that
but it's like I like all the stories
though because they want these kind of
like romantic story was based on so
don't go look in there because you'll
probably just like die yeah you'll just
like die of thirst or whatever looking
there's nothing there by lottery ticket
it's a lot cheaper alright so that will
wrap up our show about the Lost Dutchman
mine and the Superstition Mountains hope
you guys enjoyed our rambling drunken
discussion mm-hmm if you didn't then
whatever you didn't have to write you
didn't have to listen I don't know all
right yeah but anyway remember if you
like the show like share subscribe it
really helps us out a lot if you'd like
to financially support the show we have
a patreon page which you can find at 13
o'clock podcasts or you can give us a
donation on patreon PayPal rather you
can find the link on our blog which is
13 o'clock podcast WordPress icon
there's a little button that says PayPal
in the sidebar if you'd like to give a
one-time donation if you don't like
patreon for whatever reason remember are
oh and also if you're a patron you get
to see all our shows a day early so that
might be a thing that you're into and
remember our regular episodes every
Tuesday movie retrospectives which is
old movies that's every Friday and new
movies in the theater or on Netflix or
on shudder our every Sunday we do three
of them so check them all out if you
haven't already and that'll do it for
episode 157 we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]